in today's luncheon urn I'm gonna share
the top 10 best youtube tricks from
successful youtubers so I'm part of an
invite-only community that YouTube put
together for creators and it's been fun
to kind of share opinions and advice
back and forth and somebody recently
posted in there asking what is your top
tip that's had the biggest impact on
your YouTube channel and a bunch of
people left comments and they don't know
I'm sharing this so I'm gonna mute out
the faces and the names but some of the
advice is gold so for those of you who
are trying to watch your YouTube channel
I think it could help mine is adding
closed captioning to all of my videos
not only is it a great thing to do with
your viewers who are deaf or hard of
hearing but people who don't speak your
language can also use YouTube's
Translate to translate your captions
into their language YouTube has made the
process of adding captions super simple
it's also great for YouTube video
rankings and search since YouTube will
now know exactly what's said in your
video mine has been refusing to take
free products to review on our show and
instead enforce monetary product
placement in order to actually make
money on the channel instead of giving
out free press to every product that
wants exposure if I can summarize my
general YouTube experience in regards
becoming successful it can't be in this
tip find a way to innovate within your
niche or genre trying to copycat another
YouTube personality will probably not
get you very far but if you're able to
do something on YouTube that no one else
has attention will be called to it it
doesn't have to be a particularly
Herculean or academic accomplishment
even just one that YouTube has a lack of
a void you can fill for me to take
advantage of old videos you've done the
hard part filming and editing them when
an old video just Peters out and isn't
getting news anymore go in and update
the thumbnail title description and tags
I call this reanimating video it can't
hurt to try this and I've been able to
revive many old
feels that we're getting a hundred views
a day to getting twenty thousand a day
or more our best YouTube tip would be to
pay attention to the magical analytics
data that comes with every channel it's
a serious goldmine from which they gain
insight into both your viewers and your
content not only allow you to see and
understand what it is it's getting you
viewers but also providing a better
understanding of how to go about
retaining and engaging them the data is
literally at your fingertips and I'm
saying hardly any of us are utilizing it
to its fullest potential the more we
know the better we can optimize our
present content and the better we can
plan out how and what to produce with
full regard to future content I was
super excited when our first video went
over 1 million views but then I realize
how we hadn't been successful in
capturing those viewers in that moment
and translating them into an even 1
percent increase in our channel
subscribers so we needed to adjust and
look for and implement a new strategy
we've since added annotations to all of
our most popular videos and now we're
working on the second string videos as
well and we asked and directed those new
viewers to be sure to subscribe and to
visit our website within two months time
we not only have another of our videos
go over the 1 million viewer mark but we
had a 20% gain in our channel
subscribers to talk about an increase
holy subscribers Batman hook your
viewers early in the first 10 seconds
grab their attention or tease the cool
thing that will come later movies and TV
shows do this all the time with a cold
open I've been able to keep my average
audience retention at above 80% by doing
this the best tips I can give are one
focused on the title tags and the
scripting to be found on YouTube and to
collaborate with other youtubers so that
you can grow your audience those two
work for me and got lots of views and
subscribers in just a few days
don't promote anywhere you can check
your analytics and drop communities that
give you low audience retention it will
actually penalize your YouTube rankings
first impressions are sometimes the most
important video thumbnails are one of
the best ways to boost views but make
sure it's on topic and doesn't mislead
the viewers hook them with a welcome
post thumbnail and keep them around for
the video content
honestly just have fun with it if you're
here just for the money or fame you're
gonna have a bad time if you enjoy
making the content then your audience
will know and in the long run you won't
get burned out the tip that I added to
it was consistency to be consistent
every day put out content your audience
grows you get better your skills develop
your technique develops and you get
momentum coming and people get used to
coming to your channel I'm making you
part of their daily routine consistency
consistency consistency it's so easy to
start off and have tons of momentum I
energy and ideas and then it fades and
fizzles and then you try to get back on
again and then it fades and fizzles so
if you can be consistent every single
day you're much more likely to have
success so thank you guys for watching
I'd love to know which of the tips
you're gonna implement had the biggest
impact on you leave it below and I'd
also love to know what your number one
tip as a youtuber is shared in the
comments will join the discussion take
you guys so much for watching and
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon